okay okay and Warner Brothers pictures
new movie fistfight the students wage an
epic prank war against the teachers on
senior prank day in honor of the film
stars Ice Cube and Charlie day have
challenged us to an epic prank war of
our own I don't know much about pranks
because apparently what I find funny
other people find awful and dangerous
I'm not worried about Zack he's gonna be
delight but I am worried about Ned oh
man you guys drank war I have been the
victim of so many pranks from the other
three guys they've broken into my house
they kidnapped my wife my pranks will be
specifically tailored to eat to the
other Thai guys to get revenge right so
what's the plan what are you guys gonna
do so we're doing a whole day pranks
guys a prank and each other yeah
it's a prank war somebody should get
somebody else's girlfriend pregnant
that's the oldest trick in the book yeah
yeah can we do wife instead of
girlfriend cuz he's better yeah yeah
actually a prison after this percentage
25 the line you guys are making this
sound very fun only time this fun is
after the prank is oh it's okay for
everybody to laugh once their lives of
[Music]
warning good morning at is boring I've
gone another level day guys just be
careful this elevator I might have done
something to it I'm not gonna prank
people by making them feel bad or
hurting them I'm gonna prank them by
constantly experiencing me it's for good
if it what happened
Sagi yours is adorable no I hated this
took so long last night and I was so
unhappy doing it my goal for today is to
take the most classic basic pranks and
pull them off did you just fart
you think the stupidest pranks shed some
light on the situation
yeah this is gonna cheats everywhere yes
[Music]
what's gonna good prank right catch oh
no it's just that just a snake really
bad pranks I'm really bad at pranks
I have a package downstairs oh goodness
that is a big package oh my gosh what a
big package what is it
did I win a trophy or something he
spelled my name that corn-fields
ned knows that I hate my name being
misspelled it's just a pet peeve of mine
let's all give a round of applause for
Zach you could like find somebody's
internet search history and make that
public so you're saying you could use
computers to your advantage might have
to do a little trolling but that's okay
we call it research Keith what why am i
tagged in 800 photos of just you what
did you do I just asked my friends and
followers if they would hatch tag you
teeth day yeah Keith day it's a holiday
I came up with this idea to get a bunch
of extra Keith's around the office so I
used LA's resource of tons of actors to
find people who look just like me so pop
quiz what's your name hey what's your
favorite thing in the world
I'm smiling and Keith don't you be tough
Keith really excited kid sneaky
emotional he's sexy ki sexy cute ha ha I
just keep so sexy ha ha wait here for
lunch keys I have a hot date and that's
what you are where you came from leave
my wife out of this okay
ya gotta think Keith is coming in that
give him a pine face booyah
you big paw that's so rude which keith
is this I'm the real people
yeah he's the real kin ki KI
god damn it kid my plan from here on out
is to eliminate as many keeps as
possible whatever it takes however many
pies it takes I will destroy our keys
until only my true love remains
everywhere there's a Keith I'm gonna put
an end
just so beautiful prank one thing Keith
hates most is not being the center of
attention so I'm gonna steal the show
I'm gonna fire back that we create is do
your own Janette is infuriating yes
beautiful Keith yeah how many times
gonna get you in a whoopie cushon what
y'all think about bringing in the animal
kingdom into pranks well Long's is no
like your sharpest a gerbil knows what
it wants and that's the promise it's
gonna determine to get it
trust me I know so we have two meals
here with fake cockroaches and then for
key we're gonna put the real roaches on
I want to load them into a false sense
of security by using fake bugs and
animals until BAM I hit them with some
zoology med Oh John rubber roaches
there's key what's oh god I look much
more convincing than you purse yeah no
there's a road to the potatoes here
good nice you don't give me roaches and
then say Oh be nice to them they're bugs
there's another one freakin down there
I'm sorry if I overreacted guys let me
just say I am sorry if my pranks have
gone too far for any dude
[Music]
oh that Cologne I know you have a date
with your wife tonight this is so groan
oh you know what this it's it's okay I
planned for something like this luckily
Zak ruins Ned shirt and that has to wear
a shirt with my face on it because I
made some shirts with my face on it
let's upgrade this shirt yeah that's a
seat Eugene is always so vain so today I
want to make Eugene look a little less
pretty that is basically turned into his
full acro self what color is this Ned oh
you know like a poopy brown all right we
got called down to the prop closet
because we haven't cleaned our prop
closet
that was as bad as I expected
wow there's a lot of bad stuff yeah not
ours
Eugene hates happiness so I'm gonna
surprise him that seemed very happy
things I'm not Oh No
ah I don't like hugs and kept saying it
love me can I pay you to punch this
there right so bears gonna follow you
around all day guys right being
distracted with you to get to work
what does that is that voice your fly's
down
with me hey keeps our bag got some
reinforcements
what if you just like all made out with
you no I don't I don't know if they I
mean sexy or Kowhai I don't know if just
get sex to keep the pack I'm not sure
it's a tiny pack oh that would look
great on you though thank you very much
Shazam why you keep killing kids uh it
did all your work for you I know I you
were an emotional key I decided matter
with us John it should be fun yeah I got
that you know and you get killed
two of my kids come on let's get you
cleaned up
can you see that they're right there
what right there what about it you see
it now
Oh what that's not a prank one of my
favorite stories about Zack is his huge
phobia of tiny fish no Eugene I can't
see is this what Dad girl I'll guide
your head I'll help you okay thanks I'm
a good friend here yeah I got no Eugene
no no stop no you're cheating
they're kissing me they're kissing my
you have food for them you gotta have a
super prank own day but you never pull
it out to his time to go nuclear
oh goodness just a bathroom
many of my pranks are gonna be taking
place in the bathroom because that's
where people are the most vulnerable
because they literally have their pants
down when you go to the toilet that's
like your private time
you don't expect a lizard to be jumping
up into your business Eugene you're
gonna pay for this what is happening oh
my god oh my god oh my god Eugene
decided to frame me with birds which is
the best news ever they're pink
flamingos I'm trying to leave Canada
well how about those trees take a selfie
with six inches
one of my all-time favorite pranks is
stealing people's stuff and encasing it
in gelatin no collection would be
complete without a photo of mr. and mrs.
fummer oh I mean this is funny but I
also don't use a keyboard
fYI um these are definitely Quinta set
but then I have one more thing for you
oh no no no it's not that
that wasn't today he was a real today
net was just being it Ned was the worst
ah pranked Frank moreover right a man
seeking revenge I feel like I got my
revenge this confirm that I don't like
pranks I could have you more thrilled
with out today when I brought out the
real animals so I tricked them there but
uh no one got hurt
I'm just glad that the other three guys
didn't gang up on me but you never pull
it out to his time to go nuclear
I got a lizard
laughs Hermes feels pretty gross that's
amazing I want something goes that my
car wait you tell us it's got your name
on it how did I even get here Ned oh
we're sure ah the giant snake
see we kind of expected that Ned's
entire agenda was revenge
sweet Otis car here covered in post-it
notes inside of it Keis oh hello